amex 2008-2009 we saw 247 oil services
deals at about thirty two billion
dollars in the NP space we only saw 51
deals worth about 6.6 billion dollars
got any good number projections for me
at least on the oil services side there
if you look across the landscape there
really aren't that many big big deals
that could potentially come through I
mean you had they already did it there's
a rarity kind of happen exactly i mean
you know Chalmers a vine can baker
hughes and Halliburton you know maybe
you throw out GE and nov coming in
scooping up assets if you look at have
some fmc technologies their competitor
of Cameron drill quip Oceaneering or
some other names that have been floating
around the M&A landscape so you know but
those companies are you know under 10
billion dollars you're talking about the
baby peeps Halliburton deal was you know
40 billion dollar deal the Cameron deals
15 billion dollars so you know it just
doesn't seem like you're going to have
the same size materialized that you've
kind of seen in the past 12 months
really in a domestic E&P space if you
have to go back to X on buying XTO as
the last large major transformative
acquisition in a domestic E&P space well
they've seen many left like andrew was
saying in the oil services or is there
another reason for that well I think the
reason here is at once x dot was exxon
bought XTO they took on a great deal
gasps gasps II assets the investor base
had a very negative reaction to that so
some of the larger integrated names
could still be feeling some of that
uncertainty there and picking up a
sizable player in the domestic market
but what we have seen over time has been
assets being sold and that will likely
continue into 2016 part of the whole
strategy on the old services side is
going to be technology-driven vertical
integration is in terms of our versus
more horizontal or consolidate Ori moves
and what that does is like you said is
they're lowering the cost per barrel to
the EMP customers which inherently you
know is in the best interest of them in
propping up activity which keeps
production higher or
resilient or more buoyant and you know
puts downward pressure on prices or
keeps a cap on prices more or less is
that kind of constellation in M&A that
we're seeing through the EMPs factored
in yet to the oil price and production
estimates here in the US well I think
what we've seen here is that the
resiliency of the output despite the
significant price decline what we have
seen is that the EMPs are bringing their
cost structures down as quickly as they
can in this environment of lower-cost